[Music]
i don't know what to say
we are this close
to losing our priceless spot on hbo max
this is one thorn this close to our side
the rest of the properties is a lot of
fun but this one is a lot a lot of
difficulty i've gotten messages about
are you sure you want to keep talking
about this craig
and i said hey you know i would never
agree to be on a press list if i can't
be honest
and you know what i just don't i don't
get the situation okay all right so
last week we did a video about how wb
released
the justice league trailer the 4k
edition
and at that time ray porter and zack
snyder had yet commented on the fact
that they did it
and yeah they're all like yeah they're
going too far they're going too far
and then uh john found this story today
which is like a lot of people on social
media are talking about the fact that
wb has announced uh you know like
they're officially going forward with
like
black superman it will be clark kent if
i'm not mistaken
yada yada yada but here's what's going
on the bottom line
zack snyder he said wb doesn't want to
work with him anymore
and it's been reported from samba tv
samba also be my favorite song
on dance central on xbox connect that
the viewership is is really
really i just don't get it it's hi i
don't get it john
please what's going on in the world take
it away yeah okay so samba tv from my
understanding is a company that has
helped various
networks and purveyors of television and
movies get on to you know smart tvs and
stuff so they have a lot of access to
viewership across the world i don't know
a hundred percent
how comprehensive all their numbers are
or if
you know an internal report from hbo max
would differ but they have been
reporting on the schneider cuts
performance actually since it dropped
and uh this week they're reporting that
in the first 39 days of its viewership
it's gotten 3.7
million views which is i think double
what it started out with which was 1.8
million views a lot of people were
saying and they have a nifty graphic
showing you
uh also the wonder woman 1984 opening
which i believe is 2.2 million
it's also got godzilla vs kong in mortal
kombat just for reference even though
those films came out well after but
for a movie that is a you know recut of
something that a lot of people are
already familiar with it seems like a
strong viewership
across the board i mean even if the
opening
was a bit weaker than a wonder woman
1984 that's a new sequel to a
popular movie exactly you know whereas
this is
a passion for a lot of people but is
already familiar to a lot of people
you gotta factor in context to the max
here it's so important you factor in
context
the fact that it's even coming close to
the numbers
of new movies new theater
movies that could have made a bit like i
don't know if mortal kombat would have
but from what everyone's saying it seems
like it maybe could have
mortal kombat godzilla vs kong wonder
woman 84
these are movies that were meant to be
brand new
brand new in the theaters so there's an
excitement about
that and also they're not four hours
long
and they don't take convincing okay yeah
that's a great example i was in colorado
and i was talking with a with a
gentleman
it was asking about like have you heard
about this zack snyder's just like
asking me because he doesn't know what i
do
if you're the zack snyder's justice
league and i had to tell him like
yeah like here's what's what happened
yeah you know because he he's like yeah
some people are here talking about it
but i don't know like should i watch it
and that's my point is that there's a
lot of people
who might take some convincing to take
time to watch this other than saying
like it's better than the one that came
out a few years ago yeah
the fact that this movie is coming close
to matching those numbers
especially doubling in viewership
meaning strong word of mouth
yeah re-watchability like for a
four-hour film re-watchability
these are all great indicators of a
strong
film yeah whether or not your personal
opinion means you like it or don't like
it
the numbers speak for themselves i've
always been taught that you got to look
at results and numbers are the name of
the game
so to me this speaks more volumes than
anything else
like all the other stuff with like wwe
84 and all them none of that's
surprising like
who doesn't expect that like what what
upheaval battle
do those movies have zack snyder's
justice league heads
you gotta fight to get viewers on that
one a lot more yeah you would have to
get
for brand new films yeah and i mean the
other thing is
i don't know if we have much of the data
on when people click off of those other
new release movies because they did say
it seems like people made it a bit over
two hours into
justice league before a lot of
households started clicking off or
whatever
um but even still i would be curious to
know what that retention
is for a wonder woman or for a godzilla
i'm sure it's
pretty high for a godzilla but uh the
other thing too is that these numbers
are only the u.s numbers i think for the
most recent report of these 39 days
there's also an additional 1.4 million
viewers in the uk
and we also got a factor in the hbo max
is not available everywhere and wherever
this might have been shown in theaters
is not
everywhere so it seems like there's also
potentially more growth
to come the movie's way as it gets out
to the rest of the world
you know and it's funny to know it seems
like they really do have a sort of
personal
stake in the situation beyond just the
business of it
it seems like zack snyder's role in this
wb's role in this the fans role in this
it seems like there is a certain level
of
like when zack snyder responds things
like that on vero to people about yeah
they crossed the line with this new
trailer and yeah they don't even want me
i believe that you know because of just
the way
yeah i mean it's it's strange to me
because it does seem like there is a lot
of money that could be made
from this pivot but at the same time it
really does feel like at least from the
wb side of things they just wanted to
put the bow on this and move past
i don't think it's a smart call at all i
hope they they change their minds down
the line
when i'm so curious no like zack snyder
even came out recently and said that he
was scared to
champion the snyder cut because he was
worried that wb might actually
sue him or try to silence him and so
these like little tidbits that zack
snyder says these
little little things look at today for
example nor
want me it's all he said yeah i mean
clearly that means wb doesn't want me
there's no
there's no reading into that yeah that's
pretty direct i can't imagine
just like what he is feeling about this
right now
yeah you know he worked his ass off he
proved
that his version is a superior version
yeah and
the fan base he has no other dceu
property has this level of pat
i think the only one that came close to
having this level of passion
is joaquin phoenix's joke yeah but
that's not even this that's not a
universe
that is joaquin phoenix this
is an entirely different beast
and i do think that like the fact of how
wb is going about it by just trying to
ignore everything like you go online
it's black superman news breaks
what do i see trending on twitter ray
fisher
yeah and i'm sure a lot has that
probably factors in bottom line
this movie coming to fruition and
getting on hbo max has led to a lot of
slamming against wb so i don't
fully you know it's not like i don't get
why they would be dismayed
like i can't say that i can't be like oh
no you guys are
dumbasses you know i i i get it why
there'll be people who are taking it
personal
yeah but it's business you shouldn't
take it personal follow what's what's
going and flowing don't go down the path
of what's getting like downvoted and
stuff
well yeah and it's only gonna make the
elephant in the room bigger not to
acknowledge it you know and that's why
i'm kind of surprised that like nobody
picked up these numbers back when at
least the opening weekend ones dropped
so that we could at least dissect this
but you know i don't know guys is any of
this surprising anymore
i don't know what's going on i think
everyone's just over it and zack
snyder's gonna move on to greener
pastures and we're all going to
have that justice league and those
storyboards to save us for a timeline
that could have been let him make like
an animated movie or something
sure i think that would be so cool if
they let him make like at least
dude dc animated we'll give him like
yeah just give him like a dc animated
movie at the very least
yes i know that's not that's not what a
lot of people want to be down for that
but
i think dak snyder could do a pretty
awesome one if there's a way to let it
carry on
because movies are already like
paintings so might as well
he's done animation once before he could
do drawn animation this time like that's
true sherlock gnomes
that's right and happy feet
[Laughter]
all right guys i'm starting to get
discouraged but no we must restore the
snyder verse
i want 5.9 million views by next month
what's it gonna take 10 billion views
100 billion views break the internet
passion viewership
fan demand every fan what will it take
every fan needs to buy a vpn open
several hbo accounts
just leave them running on the snyder
cut multiple views a day
just just drive it up what do you want
wb what will it take
what do you want anyway guys subscribe
to the real rejects
click that notification bell hit that
like button
last but not least
i want to shout out a man named michael
b
michael b we gotta collab again dude
omni media
blowing up on youtube man first one to
get out tv show reactions
all the time even before the episodes
come out he's doing some illegal [ __ ]
but
it's the name of the game you know
whatever it takes
man whatever it takes to skyrocket in
the reaction game
michael i love you dude may the fifth be
with you
my white friend absolutely i hope that
you and your lady are doing great i hope
that
this year in 2021 you reach
14 000 subscribers oh yeah that's only
800 more i think you need to get 15 and
a half
don't stop there man shoot for that 14.5
you got this buddy in all sincerity we
need to do another collab
you're a fun guy to talk to you're a
handsome gentleman you're more
knowledgeable
than both john
oh yeah probably
still yeah just me
anyway see you buddy